[Norvig] So the args notation appears in 2 places.
It appears in the definition of a function, and it can appear in a function call.
In the definition of a function, what it means is this function can take any number of arguments
and they should all be joined up into a tuple called args.
So if the call to the function looked like this, something(f, 1, 2, 3),
then 1, 2, 3 would be bound up into a tuple and assigned to args.
So within the body of something, args is equal to the tuple (1, 2, 3).
And then this part here means take that tuple and apply it not as a single argument
but rather, unpack it and apply it to all those arguments.
So fn(args) is equivalent to writing fn(1, 2, 3).
It's just a way of packing and unpacking arguments with respect to function calls.
One thing I want you to notice here is that we used a function as a variable,
as a parameter or something that's passed into another function.
We're using the property of Python that functions are first class objects
just like integers and lists and everything else.
Functions are objects that you can pass around.
That's very powerful because that way we can control both what happens
and when it happens.
The idea here is that we want to call this function
but we want to delay calling of the function until we've already started the clock.
We want it to happen between the time we start the clock and the time we end the clock.
And in order to do that, if we tried to write something like this--
timedcall(zebrapuzzle())--then timedcall wouldn't work.
It would be too late because what we pass to timedcall
would be the result of zebrapuzzle.
We don't want to pass the result; we want to pass the function that we're going to call
and be able to delay execution of that function until the right time,
until we're ready to set the clock.
And so functions allow us to do that--to delay execution until later.